Okay Michael, so, this is it. Why don't you help me remember what we
learned in this one marathon session that
was not all distributed over multiple months.
>> [LAUGH] Sure. Or years.
>> Mm hm.
>> So, MDPs. So, we talked about mark-off
decision processes, and we said what that meant. [LAUGH]
>> Okay, so, that's the first thing we did is we talked about MDPs.
>> And that, that MDP consists of states and rewards and actions and
like that, transitions, discounts.
>> So you said discounts and I just want to point out that there are
some people who think that that's a part of the definition of the problem
and there are some people who think that that's more of a parameter to
your algorithm. okay, alright. So there's some
people who think of it the right way.
>> Like me. And some people think of it the wrong way. So, I
tend to think of the discount as
being something that you're allowed to fiddle with,
as opposed to it being a fundamental part of the.
>> Then why not fiddle with the rewards?
>> Sure. You are allowed to fiddle with the rewards.
>> Oh! You are very open minded!
>> I am open minded, i believe that rewards should be able
to marry other rewards. In any case, the important thing here is
that there is some under lying process that you care about that
is suppose to represent the world,
states, rewards, actions, and transitions and capture
that fairly well. Discount is, in some sense, an important part of the
problem, because it tells you how much you want to care about the future
versus the past. But it's reasonable to think of that as something that you
might want to change outside of the kind of underlying physics of the world.
>> I see. Okay, that's fair. Yeah, in some sense, the states and
the actions and the transitions represent.
The physical world and the rewards and
the discount represent the kind of task description.
>> Right. And of course, you say that, but
if you, you could decide to define states differently, and
doing that would impact both your actions and the
transition function and so on and so forth. But the
basic idea is right, which is, there's some underlying
process we're trying to capture, and I think it's exactly
right to say, states, actions, and transitions. Sort of capture
that. And rewards and discounts capture more about the nature
of the task, you're trying to do in that underlying world.
>> Okay. And in, in that context we talked
about two really important concepts. Policies and, value functions?
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which we sometimes call utilities.
>> Right.
>> And how do utilities differ from rewards? The utilities factor in the
long term aspects, and the rewards are just telling you the moment to moment.
>> Right.
>> Utilities are like a group of rewards. Like a gaggle.
>> Or a murder.
>> Of crows. So, that we talked about how we
can assign value to an infinite sequence of rewards. Mm-hm.
>> But it helps if we use discounting to
do that so that we don't get infinitely large sums.
>> And that allowed us to deal with infinite sequences, but threat them as if
their value is, in fact, finite, thus solving the immortality problem.
>> [LAUGH] And, let's see, then we kind of.
And the stationarity was a really important part of that.
>> Yep. In fact kind of drove everything.
>> Yeah. And all these things were
tied up together in the bellman equation itself.
>> Yes which is an awesome equation and deserves capital letters. [LAUGH]
Is that it? And then, well then we solve the Bellman
equation using value iteration and policy iteration.
>> Oh, yes.
>> I think that was it. Alright,
so are any of these polynomial time algorithms?
>> Well, the way we've been talking about them, no, but you can map
these into linear programs and turn them
into polynomial problems, or polynomial. So, yes these
problems can be solved that way. But
actually, that reminds me, of something that
we haven't said and that we haven't
learned today, that I think is worth mentioning.
Which is we been talking about, you know, this section
of the class is about over the course is about
reinforcement learning. But, we actually haven't done any reinforcement learning
here because we know everything, we know the states, we
know the rewards, we know the actions, we know the
transitions. We have some discount, we have been solving MDP's,
but that's not quite the same thing [SOUND] as doing
reinforcement learning, however, it's very important to do these things,
to make it easier to think about how reinforcement learning works. So,
in reinforcement learning, the difference is,
you don't necessarily know, the rewards
and the transitions or even the states and the actions, for that
matter. I see. So when are we going to get into reinforcement learning then?
>> Next time. And when I say we next time, I mean you next
time. That's your assignment. Learn all about
reinforcement learning and talk about it next time.
>> All right. I gotta go and get
to work then.
>> Okay. Well, you have a good one Michael.
>> Thanks for all this. It's really cool.
>> It is cool. Bye.
>> Bye.